nothing in life is free not even ten  dollar items in destiny the game's big  December update caused a few issues  including an exploit that let players  acquire the sparrow racing league record  book vol 1 without purchasing it now the  book has been closed on the issue if you  acquired the record book normally but  lost it in the patch don't worry  bungie's working on a solution to  restore any items accidentally deleted  by the fix additional problems such as  exotic leg ngrams not decrypting and a  future war cult ship incorrectly  providing reputation have also been  solved destiny's december update tweaked  many weapons and crucible systems and  introduced the sparrow racing league to  the galaxy you can visit bungees website  for full notes on any of the games  patches and for full coverage on bungie  space shooting RPG you're already in the  right place